[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas en Colombia la
voluntad del gobierno de Gustavo Petro y
Francia Márquez de lograr la paz total
Trata de llegar a todos los estratos
sociales Incluso en las cárceles en
Bogotá en la prisión de la picota se
instaló una mesa Nacional de negociación
donde participaron los ex jefes de los
principales grupos armados del conflicto
y hasta allí llegaron nuestros
reporteros Luis Muñoz y Lionel pushley
las cárceles de Colombia no están
exentas de la actualidad en la picota la
mayor del país los reclusos participaron
en la instalación de la mesa nacional
por la paz total concepto acuñado por el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y su
vicepresidenta Francia Márquez detrás
del evento instituciones pero también
organizaciones sociales como Esperanza
Bustamante de la corporación corazón
humano que Acompaña a mujeres en prisión
y todos ellos pueden ser interlocutores
para las personas que están afuera de
que se unan al proceso del pase en el
evento participan desde excombatientes
de la guerrilla de izquierda de las FARC
hasta antiguas autodefensas también
conocidas como paramilitares y
vinculadas a la ultraderecha guardan los
secretos de 70 años de conflicto la mesa
pretende que se aporte a la verdad y
poder reparar a las víctimas con
testimonios como el de Martín Llanos
antiguo comandante de las autodefensas
campesinas del casanare y de su padre
Héctor buitrago uno de los primeros
fundadores de las autodefensas del país
la libertad y la paz Es lo mejor que hay
para el ser humano los gobiernos que han
manejado este país No han permitido la
inclusión de todos sus ciudadanos
Entonces nos hemos enfrascado en una
confrontación de derecha y de izquierda
pero que al final no hemos podido lograr
nada
los presos que participan confían en que
se cumpla una máxima las cárceles son el
reflejo de la sociedad y en Colombia
personas que un día se mataron por unos
ideales llevan años conviviendo
pacíficamente en celdas como Jacinto
Alberto Soto toro alias Lucas el que
fuera el jefe financiero de los hermanos
castaño uno de los clanes más temidos de
la historia de Colombia y Alexander
botía político detenido por supuestos
vínculos con las disidencias de las FARC
esta imagen
de convivencia y respeto que se lleva
dentro de los establecimientos
carcelarios ha sido precisamente el
producto de haber desescalado el
conflicto de esta manera a través de
estos procesos de paz que se han llevado
a cabo en nuestro país nosotros vivimos
en un espacio de nueve metros cuatro
personas y no nos agarramos a pelear por
nada él puede roncar el otro todo lo que
sea pero no no tenemos problema eso es
lo que nos ha generado nosotros la
confianza de poderle manifestar al mundo
exterior a las sociedades que sí puede
haber paz que pueda haber convivencia si
exista la diferencia es el primer paso
que dará lugar a meses de negociaciones
entre los distintos frentes del
conflicto para lograr al fin una nueva
historia para Colombia
el aborto fue uno de los principales
temas en las elecciones de medio término
en los Estados Unidos tanto así que se
convirtió en uno de los factores clave
para que el partido de gobierno
mantuviera la mayoría demócrata en la
cámara alta Nueva York que es uno de los
estados más permisivos del país ha
recibido una avalancha de mujeres
provenientes de Estados mucho más
restrictivos el siguiente es un informe
de mamen sala
un grupo de detractores del aborto trata
de convencer a las pacientes que llegan
de que no interrumpan su embarazo
en contraposición maryló y su equipo de
voluntarios velan porque las mujeres
puedan entrar seguras al centro
asistencial Desde que la Corte Suprema
anuló el derecho al aborto en Estados
Unidos
como saben que muchas mujeres vienen a
la clínica de choices para su cita el
sábado que es el día que muchos no
trabajan vienen aquí cada sábado
estos voluntarios toman posición de
defensa para abrir las puertas a
pacientes a las que Marley Hoffman
asistirá para interrumpir sus embarazos
Si antes teníamos cinco o seis pacientes
al mes ahora Estamos recibiendo 15 a la
semana por la nueva ley y tenemos muchas
chicas y mujeres que vienen de Texas y
otros estados que han prohibido el
procedimiento
en Texas el aborto se castiga con
Prisión De por vida por eso muchas
mujeres buscan tratamiento aquí donde la
seguridad es máxima en 1970 Hoffman
estableció uno de los primeros centros
del país cuando Nueva York legalizó el
aborto desde entonces en este estado se
permite interrumpir el embarazo hasta
las 24 semanas de gestación una ley que
atrae a pacientes realmente jóvenes
sí tenemos pacientes tan jóvenes como 11
o 12 años porque muchas veces son
Víctimas de violación o violadas en su
familia o abusadas
el procedimiento exige una gran
resiliencia y ronda los 3000 dólares por
eso Hoffman habla de un nuevo término
aborcionó mix
sí vemos niñas Pero sabes muchos de
estos republicanos aman ver niñas
teniendo niños a pesar de los
detractores las clínicas de Nueva York
realizaron un 12% más de abortos en
cinco meses que en 2021 los expertos
aseguran que esta cifra podría aumentar
aún más ante la avalancha de mujeres
llegadas de otros estados más
restrictivos
con cerca de 5000 casos registrados los
hospitales libaneses se enfrentan a
nuevos desafíos en la lucha contra el
brote de cólera que ha aparecido en el
país después de 30 años y que ha puesto
en alerta a toda la región la situación
de vulnerabilidad de la población
libanesa la crisis económica y el
limitado acceso al agua y el saneamiento
ponen en peligro de contagio a todo el
país el siguiente es un reportaje de
etel
El pequeño Mohamed ya se ha recuperado
el cólera se infectó hace unas semanas
cuando la enfermedad se extendió en los
campamentos de arsal ahora su madre
alias Toma las medidas necesarias para
prevenir que el resto de las familias Se
contagie
enfermo no pensé que pudiera ser cólera
no había oído hablar de esa enfermedad
desde que era una niña estamos alerta
por si hay más casos Así que no dejo que
mis hijos estén en contacto con otras
tiendas el cólera reaparecido después de
30 años con más de 4.800 casos la
mayoría en el norte del Líbano la
localidad de arsal donde se concentra el
mayor número de refugiados es una zona
de alto riesgo para hacer frente al
brote de cólera las ong sobre el terreno
ayudan con las tareas de desinfección y
supervisión de los suministros de agua
en las áreas afectadas
tener acceso suficiente a cantidad y
calidad de agua segura es una de las
medidas preventivas más importantes para
que no se extienda el brote de cólera La
amenaza del cólera se ha disparado en el
Líbano responsables de la salud estiman
que el número de afectados podría
superar los 300.000 debido a la
virulencia de la cepa actual con una
tasa de letalidad del 2%. los casos de
cólera también han aparecido en los
núcleos urbanos como este vecindario
concienciar a los vecinos en la
prevención de la enfermedad es otra las
medidas que más puede ayudar al tener la
epidemia Así que
la situación crítica a los hospitales
libaneses por el deterioro de la
economía presenta nuevos desafíos para
lucha contra el cólera
hemos puesto a disposición todos
nuestros recursos con este hospital de
emergencia y la campaña de vacunación
pero el problema es que muchas familias
no tienen acceso a agua limpia ni
desinfectantes si no frenamos el cólera
la capacidad hospitalaria se verá
desbordada
la epidemia se está extendiendo
rápidamente y amenaza con un dial al
Líbano en más incertidumbre
desesperación y crisis si no urgentes
para garantizar el acceso a agua y
saneamiento los brotes de cólera
volverán con regularidad en el futuro el
invierno ha llegado a los frentes de
batalla del donbas en Ucrania donde se
libran cruentas batallas y donde las
temperaturas ya son gélidas los campos
ya están nevados y los ríos congelados
estas circunstancias son extremadamente
duras para el ejército ucraniano que
lleva peleando muchas veces sin descanso
desde el 24 de febrero visitamos el
frente de toresk para ver cómo se viven
estas condiciones para las tropas
informe de Catalina Gómez Ángel
el comandante Max va camino a comprobar
que todo esté bien en las posiciones que
tiene su mando este es el lugar donde
viven y de allí se dirigen al punto de
observación las temperaturas que ya
bajan de Cero y lo congelan todo han
traído nuevos retos en el frente de
toresc en el don vast donde las fuerzas
ucranianas y rusas están a pocos metros
de distancia
ahora ahora todo parece normal pero Hace
media hora esto era el infierno todo el
mundo estaba escondido en sus trincheras
esta posición estaba bajo el cuidado de
hombres que como Max se alistaron como
voluntarios después de la invasión rusa
el 24 de febrero
el invierno viven aquí por periodos que
se extienden hasta tres semanas
en mi opinión creo que si estábamos
preparados para estas condiciones
porque nosotros somos voluntarios y
estamos listos para todo
las dificultades actuales en las que
todavía se ultiman detalles para tener
todo listo para el invierno no se
comparan con lo que soportaron al
comienzo de la Guerra el ejército
ucraniano no estaba preparado para
recibir tantos voluntarios
hay ciertas dificultades y asuntos por
resolver Porque algunos hombres tienen
que estar de servicio en el frente y
usar su ropa invernal personal debajo de
sus uniformes eso ciertamente crea
ciertos inconvenientes
el barro que cubrió esas trincheras en
otoño se ha secado Pero esto también
crea oportunidades para el enemigo
para mí el clima actual es más difícil
porque cuando el clima es más templado
hay nubes y llueve Entonces no hay
drones alrededor como consecuencia de la
niebla Así que lo que hago es ponerme
los zapatos y salir cuando hay barro en
el piso está resbaladizo y hay
posibilidades de caerse porque en la
oscuridad no vemos nada y nos movemos
sin linterna
muchos hablado de que los frentes de
batalla pueden detenerse durante el
invierno cuando el barro se congela y
las temperaturas bajen a menos 20 bajo
cero pero aquí dicen que eso es un mito
de guerra que cuando se les ordena
atacar no hay condición climática que
valga
Gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información